Hey, we've, we've got a voicemail this morning
that I don't really understand and I want
to get your help in interpreting our voicemail
number of courses.
Two one nine two David P, what do you think
this voicemail caller is talking about?
Take a listen.
Yes.
Hi David.
This is James.
I'll leave a message and [inaudible] right
now.
However, uh, my concern is the Bernie Sanders
thing.
I it just a distraction.
Alright.
I don't get it.
Is the Bernie Sanders thing a distraction?
What is the Bernie Sanders thing?
Is it like a, you do mean that he's running
for president or what would it be a distraction
from like, I genuinely don't understand what
this caller is suggesting.
Is the implication that Bernie has no shot
and therefore running is the distraction or
does he mean that media coverage?
Some particular stuff.
I mean I just have no idea what this person
is asking about.
Is the Bernie Sanders thing.
Just the distraction.
I don't know what you mean, but if anybody
in the audience can help me interpret it,
I would very much appreciate it.
On the bonus show today we will talk about
a Los Angeles executive who got their son
into USC as a fake water polo player has been
sentenced to four months in prison.
Is that a fair sentence?
We will discuss.
We will also talk about a European court saying
that the right to be forgotten only applies
to websites inside the European union, which
is a really important ruling because up until
now there was the presumption that if you
are living in the European union, but you
are accessing websites like Google for example,
or another US-based website, that the right
to be forgotten still applies.
And this decision, uh, suggests that it does
not.
And, uh, Turkish, uh, leader Erdowan says
that nuclear power should be either free for
everybody or banned altogether.
We will talk about all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show, two ways to get
instant access to the bonus show.
Become a member
by signing up@joinpacman.com very quick, very
easy, or become a patron at patrion.com/david
Pakman show.
I'll see you then, or on tomorrow's show,
the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.